it is a very difficult morning in the
deep south where a devastating tornado
outbreak swept across several states and
caused a disaster near auburn alabama at
least 23 people were killed in lee
county by the deadliest tornado since
the one that hit in Moore Oklahoma in
2013 the twister that destroyed homes
businesses and lives was one of a dozen
reported in Alabama yesterday
in the northeast parts of that same
system dumped more than a foot of snow
in some areas overnight it was the final
act of a powerful storm front that raced
across the country over the weekend we
have correspondents in the southeast and
the Northeast but we begin with mark
Strassmann and Beauregard Alabama where
their tornado damage is described as
catastrophic mark good morning good
morning this is County Road 38 and there
were fatalities on this road you can see
why the homes on both sides are gone
just god there's a eerie beeping sound
going off behind me those are smoke
detectors going off but there's no one
here left to answer them because that is
the only sign of life there is here this
community scarred in every sense of the
word at first light more than 150 people
are going to fan out in a sweeping
search and rescue operation and they're
braced for the possibility of finding
more bodies oh dude that's a big tornado
Oh big oh my god is right it's in my
face the tornado was at least a half
mile wide when it touched down in Lee
County Alabama shredding everything in
its path leaving homes and businesses in
rubble people had all of 20 minutes
warning to find shelter before the
massive tornado devastated the area
houses completely destroyed homes that
just basically just slabs left were once
stood a home the contents of one
residence we know for a fact was located
over a thousand yards away the National
Weather Service says the tornado was at
least an ef3 with winds between 136 and
165 miles per hour we're talking several
miles
that had traveled on the ground the
damage is significant I would put it in
the category of catastrophic many of the
storm victims lived in Beauregard
Alabama including six-year-old AJ
Hernandez Jr on social media his aunt
called him a precious little man but
there were also stories of survival
cameras caught an emotional moment as a
grandmother was reunited with her
granddaughter and nearby Smith station a
popular bar was gutted to the studs
the owner was sitting in his truck just
feet away
I seen the trash swirling in the air
across the hill over there and I said oh
no this ain't good just across the
street charlie Patel was inside as his
gas station was torn to pieces does I'm
on the counter and ten seconds in this
tornado come and everything is gone
everything destroyed Alabama wasn't the
only state to see some serious storms
there were more than a dozen reports of
tornados in Georgia
this is drone video of talbot in' where
homes were left in piles of wood and
cars were tossed folks nearby Ellerslie
say everything was gone before they even
knew what happened everything that's
been built for 19 years in a blink of an
eye to give you a sense of the loss of
life here all last year tornadoes killed
10 people across the country yesterday
tornadoes killed more than twice as many
people in this one Alabama County Gale
mark thank you very much those pictures
are hard to watch